I have to give you props because I'm
always inspired by the powerful ladies
that you surround yourself with I think
you have so many inspiring women in your
life and I want to ask you about your TV
sister Ariel winter yeah she's become
this body positivity powerhouse and
she's inspiring so many women of all
ages yeah does it make you proud to see
her in this new light I'm proud that
she's so accepting of her by me like
Ariel is like my little sister so um I
love her so so much I think she's
beautiful inside and out and I think
everybody is beautiful inside and out no
matter if you're like chicken legs like
me or like the lump she was like Ariel
it's just um women are different and I
think that's the most beautiful thing
about them so I'm very I'm very proud of
her have you learned anything from
watching her be so vocal and out there
with everything that she is I mean I'm a
very outspoken person myself um I would
like to I would I would hope that she's
actually learned things from me from
being so outspoken myself about certain
things so um so I hope it would actually
be the opposite I mean we both like have
grown so much as people over the past
eight years so um so it's really great
but I hope that she hope she gets up
from me